Okay, moving on
with the proceedings.
I would like to look
at the next article,
which is a suspension
period in monogamy.
If we are gonna do this
for another beautiful year,
I would like to make out
with five...
ty --
"fivety" people.
50 people.
Ilana.
Two.
And I have to know
about them.
[ Squealing ]
Okay! Dope!
I mean deal.
Communication is dope.
On the long-term front,
I would like to bring up
an issue
with the state
of Maryland.
-Mm-hmm.
-I think I'd like to move there.
You just want
to up and move
to middle-of-nowhere
Maryland?
Well, I'm from there,
so my whole family
would be there.
My brother's
a dentist, also,
and we've always wanted
to start our own practice,
"The Tooth Factory."
And there's lots
of great schools there.
Schools?
So, w-w-what,
like, cars drive around them
slower, and it's safer to walk?
No. Schools are...
for the children
that I father
to attend.
Are we -- Are we still
discussing this year?
I don't really remember
reviewing this for my notes.
Well, I guess while looking
at this year's points,
I looked ahead at next year
and the year after that.
Is this about
the rom-coms?
'Cause I'll watch one
every weekend, you know?
And I'll just rip a bong
and laugh really sincerely,
and I'll learn to love them.
No, it's just that,
I want to buy a house.
I've been looking
on Zillow.
Houses aren't even
that expensive in Maryland.
And I want to have kids,
and I want to get married.
Lincoln, I'm only 27.
What am I, a child bride?
You know, I don't know
that I never want it.
I just definitely
don't want it right now.
I could commit to a kid
when I'm like...43.
Lincoln, I just figured out
that I want to go back to school
and focus on my wizness.
I'm on
a New York City timeline.
Do you ever think
you'd change your mind?
[ Indistinct conversations,
silverware clinking ]
At this point,
I can't move on this.
I have no counter.
I-I...
Well, these points are
non-negotiable for me.
♪♪
♪ Shawty says
she hate my lifestyle ♪
♪ She hate my friends,
feel like my life wild ♪
♪ She hate my lifestyle ♪
♪ I wrote this shit
up in the Chi ♪
♪ All right! All right! ♪
♪ That's where I get
all my thoughts ♪
♪ All right! All right! ♪
♪ She don't like it,
like it, though ♪
♪ All right! All right! ♪
♪ That's why you lookin'
real soft ♪
♪ All right! All right! ♪
♪ Damn it, man,
I feel like twice ♪
Riblets!
♪ It feel like scheisse ♪
♪ She stayin' at my house,
it been a few ♪
♪♪
Riblets. Am I right?
[ Groaning ]
[ Coughs ]
♪♪
God. Watch it!
S-- I am sorry.
[ Glass shatters ]
Shit!
Ohh. I'm so sorry!
-Abbi!
-Abbi?!
-Oh, my God.
-I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Uh, we were short caterers,
and Abbi's never really been
talented with the tray, so...
Oh, I'm so sorry. Actually,
Abbi's an up-and-coming artist
and my personal guest,
not a caterer.
Um, yes, she is.
So, I-I'm --
I-I'm actually catering,
but I am -- am also
a-a guest.
Okay, Ab,
we're gonna need you
to start loading some dirties
into a van, so...
Totally.
I will do that.
-Liars aren't cool.
-No, I-I kn--
I don't think
they're cool, either.
You know what?
I have to go find some canapés,
-clear my mind.
-Donna, I can get you canapés.
I can -- I can g--
I have access to all of them.
♪♪
Don't worry about her.
She can get her own canapés.
It's not that bad!
I don't even like this dress.
It's too yellow.
I am so sorry.
This is not how
this was supposed to go down.
I was so excited to be here
tonight as a guest
with all these cool
art people.
I mean, I'm actually
an artist, too.
I'm just not, like, a --
a real one.
Well, you might not
want to say that.
But it's smart to have
a flexible service job
so that you can make art.
I waited tables for years.
And I spilled
on lots of people.
In fact, half my pieces
are inspired
by people
I've spilled on.
Well, what are
your pieces like?
You might know my work.
I'm Toy Harris.
[ Scoffs, laughs ]
[ Gasps ]
You're T--
You're Toy Harris?
[ Laughs ]
Holy shit, dude.
-Oh, my God.
-You're Toy Harris?
-Yeah.
-You're the third floor.
It took us years of protesting,
but we're here.
-I cannot bel--
-It's okay.
You -- You --
I c--
So, you want to just --
you know.
I can't believe I spill--
I spilled on Toy Harris.
I spilled on Toy Harris!
-Okay.
-I am getting dizzy!
-This is insane!
-All right, then.
Good night.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Ooh!
This is not her night.